there is someone from the National
Police Association putting money behind
a lawsuit saying we're trying to get
this thing out I guarantee you the
people that work for Nashville PD wanted
out to they want to because their
officers responded in a Flawless way
technically like outstanding response to
what happened right they went out there
and they solved the problem in a way and
when you look at those guys like they
were not they were not gung-ho about
being that that wasn't the day they
planned the guy even gave his press
conference I thought it was really
emotional but they want this thing out
too because they want to say look this
is evil in the world we're calling it
out that's what you sign up this is this
is a good example of the big problem of
our attention spans in society in that
when the cops do a bad job they get all
the attention in the world when it comes
to Uvaldi their story story non-stop
questions why did this happen how did
this happen and uh we don't give enough
attention or gratitude to the officers
who do the job right as tragic as it is
but they rush in you I mean that body
camera footage of what happened it's
it's it's it's it's crazy